Okay. Let's add something new to our URLs called a
query parameter, also known as get parameters, and we'll talk
about this name shortly, when we start talking about HTTP.
Here is an example. We've got our normal URL or the
type of, the simple URL we just discussed, with a,
a simple path slash foo and we've added to the
end of this a question mark p equals one. And
this adds an actual, extra parameter whose name is P and
whose value is one. The format of a query parameter looks
like this. You've got name equals value, or in this case
P equals 1. And the value can be just about anything,
but it's good not to use question marks and other URL
characters, although you could if you really wanted. We can make
this a little bit more complicated by adding more query parameters.
Let's do that. We've added a second query parameter. The first
query parameter is separated from the UR, URL using a, question
mark. All of the following parameters are separated from each other
using ampersands. First one gets a question mark. The next one
gets an ampersand. In this case, the new parameter is Q,
and it equals the string neat. So, we have these query
parameters. What are they for? They're for basically, when you, when
you make a request for this path, this is extra information
the server gets, and there's all sorts of things you can
do with this. If this is a, a web application doing fancy
things these parameters might mean something. It can affect the
caching because technically it changes the entire URL. So there
are all sorts of handy uses that we'll discuss later
in the class for what these query parameters can do. But
they are separate from the path. But they are included
in part of the whole URL that the server sees
when you make a request. In the following URL, what
is the value of the Z parameter? Here is your URL.